تحتضنوا سلطنه عمان ثالث اكبر محميه
للسلاحف في العالم تمتاز وشواطئ ولايه صور
بانواع عديده لهذه السلاحف ما دعا هيئه
البيئه العمانيه لتاسيس فريق تطوعي لحمايه
ومراقبه ورست هذه السلاحف ومحاوله الحفاظ
عليها ايضا من تهديد الانقراض الزميل عبد
الرحمن العصيمي مع التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
تعد محميه السلاحف في راس الحد بولايه
الصور واحده من اهم المعالم السياحيه
المميزه في سلطنه عمان وتحتل مساحه 120 كم
مربعا من اراضي ساحليه وعلى امتداد الساحل
الذي يبلغ طوله حوالي 40 كيلومترا وتضم
هذه المحميه اكثر من 20,000 سلحفاه لانواع
مختلفه لذلك اطلقت هيئه البيئه العمانيه
برنامج ترتل كوماندوز لحمايه ومراقبته
السلاحف البحريه
لهذه الثروه الطبيعيه اللي هي السلاحف
البحريه لان من اصل سبعه انواع سلاحف
بحريه في العالم سلطنه عمان تزورها خمسه
انواع فهذا يعني يجعل سلطنه عمان من اهم
ثلاث مواقع في العالم همم للسلاحف هذا
البرنامج يسعى الى حمايت هذه السلاحف من
خلال رفع مستوى الوعي المجتمعيه
كثير سلوك الافراد تجاه هذه الكائنات من
اهداف برنامج دارت الكوماندس هي توعيه
المجتمع خاصه المجتمع المحلي باهميه
السلاحف البحريه لانها كونها انها ثروه
طبيعيه تسخر فيها سلطنه عمان كذلك همم
تشجيع فئه الشباب على التطوع البيئي همم
بنظافه الشواطئ من اهداف الحمله والشباب
متطوعين الاشاركونا يقوم همم تنظيف همم
قلت لكم ويندوز يهدي فوق ايضا الى تشجيعي
فئه الشباب على التطوع البيئي وذلك من
خلال مشاركه المئات من المتطوعين في
البرامج المتنوعه لحمايه السلاحف التي
اصبحت مهدده بالانقراض بسبب مخلفات
البلاستيك على الشواطئ والتلوث البيئي عبد
الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه الصور العربيه